vous allez aujourd'hui commence à
regarder ça va ça veuille ce que vous
allez bien ce que tout se passe bien ce
que tout se passe bien dans votre vie
est ce que tout va bien et ça c'est
extrêmement important au chum qui posez
vous me le marquer un banc commentaires
comment ça se passe est-ce que ça se
passe bien ou pas ici ça n'a pas trop
mal et aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'un
ordinateur parce que oui aujourd'hui on
se parle d'ordinateurs aux termes de cet
ordinateur la sas et le macbook
le macbook x pro alors le macbook x pro
on parle de la version 2021 les sur un
ordinateur 2025 et un une remise à jour
de la version qu'on avait l'année
dernière et se met debout kicks pro il
est chouette
il est intéressant il a un truc qui est
très particulier c'est un truc qu'on va
plus du tout aujourd'hui qui fait
vraiment sa force mais qui fait qu'il
est hyper hyper différents et bien c'est
qu'on a un écran
regardez-la 3/2 c'est du 3 2 me nous on
est habitué à avoir du 16/9 et la cdu 3
2 me ce qui fait que ça nous fait un
format qui est un peu bizarre comme ça
alors c'est qu'en fait on n'est plus du
tout habitué très clairement ça vous
fait des croquis en fait plus grands à
la différence du 16/9 ou sur un 16 9ème
et bien on s'arrêterait à peu près par
ici je pense voiliers et bien j'en ai un
peu plus en fait j'en ai un peu plus
pour le même prix on est à la veille de
l'écran donc ça ça me plaît bien
certaines actions qu'on a rien et son
ordinateur
on va regarder si ce mais bout qu ex pro
est intéressant en 2021 on va regarder
s'il est fait pour vous on va regarder
ce qu'on peut faire avec on va regarder
ce qu'on ne peut pas faire avec et aux
vaches et de comprendre si vous êtes
est-il et oui ou alors absolument pas
[Musique]
ah j'aime bien ces ordinateurs comme ça
j'aime bien ça me plaît bien j'aime bien
il ya beaucoup d'ordinateurs on parle de
beaucoup d'action j'ai déjà parlé d'un
ordinateur l'autre jour de huawei on
continue alors là on n'est plus du tout
sur la même cible attention soyons
clairs on n'est pas du tout sûr la baby
cible on n'est pas sur un ordinateur qui
va être dans les budgets un petit peu
moins de 1000 euros non aussi je vois
d'autres fuites on est à plus de 1000
euros on est sur deux lignes telles qu
on a soit de 8,5 soit 2007 c'est la
onzième gêne vous avez deux config 1 500
giga de ram 512 giga de stockage en ssd
et vous êtes à 1499 euros à peu près à
1500 euros soit vous êtes sur un i7
toujours saisi gars drame on monte à 1
tera de stockage toujours un ssd et on
est à 1799 euros
donc on a 300 euros d'écart pour passer
du mi5 ou i7 et également entre 512 et
un terrain de stockage en ssd
alors tout ça c'est intéressant ok donc
on voit qu'on est à 1500 à 1800 euros
sur cette machine
et qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire avec
une machine à 1500 à 1800 euros alors on
va essayer de décortiquer tout ça on va
se regarder ça ensemble on va acheter un
petit coup d'oeil déjà ou design parce
que moi ça me plaît bien ça m'intéresse
alors ce que j'aime bien ici c'est
qu'effectivement sur un ordinateur de
voir où et on a toujours des configs
extrêmement premium ça me plaît bien
on a un grand clavier ici ça c'est très
chouette j'aime beaucoup cette couleur
c'est très classe on est vraiment dans
les standards actuels clavier qui marche
bien très bon retour de touche
la cour s'est pas trop long ce qui est
cool aussi au niveau de deux châssis là
tout ce qu'on voit effectivement c'est
qu'on a les petits haut parleurs qui
viennent se situer sur le côté on un
trackpad un trackpad il est très
particulier il est très intéressant
parce que ça change des trackpad qu'on a
l'habitude de voir
on est effectivement déjà sur un grand
trackpad ça c'est bien il occupe
vraiment toute cette partie là moi
j'aime bien je veux que j'aille à un
très très bon équilibre entre la partie
clavier et la partie trackpad
donc ça marche bien et ça lui donne un
côté toujours plus premium on est sur
une gamme procès marqué si noir sur
blanc donc bien évidemment sur une gamme
pro on s'attend à voir définition de
professionnels mais ce qui est génial
ici c'est que vous n'avez pas un
trackpad qui est cliquable
on sent le clic mais en fait et j'adore
ça c'est dans cette technologie
il n'y a absolument aucun clic en
réalité alors ce qui est légal je vous
explique c'est qu'en fait normalement
sur un trackpad
on vient cliquez sur le bal à regarder
pour sentir son clic clic gauche clic
droit et bien la gelée en
je l'attendais pas sourit gilles et la
gelée la gelée la gelée la gelée la
gelée la gelée là alors on peut toujours
avoir le clic droit
les clic gauche il existe toujours mais
ce qui est génial c'est qu'il ya pas de
clip physique
on parle ici de retour haptique la
techno c'est huawei freetouch et ça
j'aime beaucoup parce que vous pourrez
venir personnaliser l'expérience
regardez combien changer la sensibilité
de la pression soit moyenne soit base
soit élevé hockey et je viens changer
également la force de la vibration
moi je les mieux élevés parce que moi je
suis je suis un mec qui vibre et il faut
que ça vibre fort donc pour le coup
c'est vraiment différent par rapport à
ce qu'on peut retrouver sur le marché
le fait d'avoir de la vibration haptique
ici ça me plaît bien en fait c'est des
petits pavés piézoélectriques que vous
avez en dessous qui vont venir fournir
cette vibration à ce retour haptique et
le gros bénéfices qu'on va avoir là
dessus au delà du côté un peu gadget et
au delà de la sensation c'est vraiment
une précision puisse jouer dans le
clavier reste on dit on a une
particularité qu'on retrouve toujours
dans les ordinateurs de huawei eh bien
c'est la petite webcam qui est planqué
alors la petite web call qui est planqué
là je voulais déjà dit si vous avez
regardé ma ville ou sur le facebook des
seize le jour je vous avais déjà parlé
par le passé elle est intéressante en
raison de confidentialité c'est à dire
que lorsque vous venez appuyer là il ya
plus de webcams personne ne peut vous
regardez bon de toute façon personne à
venir vous regardez à votre insu le gros
défaut qu'on a ici c'est qu'on ait
soulevé en contre-plongée et ça c'est
pas très très beau est-ce que vous avez
réellement envie qu'on vienne vous
parler en voyant votre round est là
parce que clairement il faut se le dire
c'est ça plus de confidentialité mais
plus de visibilité au niveau des trous
des jeux comme ça pourrait être un
slogan mais bon voilà on aime on n'aime
pas en tout cas c'est là ses planques et
d'un clavier et ça c'est un vrai
bénéfice
le bénéfice il se situe en haut sur le
fait que vous n'avez absolument aucune
caméra qui planche car on savoure tarn
et de réduire les bords et d'avoir un
design qui est très sympa leur design
parlons-en justement parce que c'est un
produit que j'aime bien je trouve super
intéressant au niveau du design très
compact sur le côté on va regarder les
connectiques dans quelques instants
tous fait un tout petit tout léger c'est
un format 14 pouces
donc ça à mettre dans une sacoche à
emmener dans un sac à dos partout vous
voulez c'est vraiment l'idéal points
positifs l'écran est tactile
ça me plaît aussi parce que le fait
d'avoir un écran tactile ça permet
d'aller loin en termes de productivité
mais la grosse particularité qu'on a au
niveau de cet écran c'est connaître un
écran 3 k fulvio vous avez un écran que
que déjà 91% la face avant c'est
beaucoup c'est bien et c'est très
confortable en termes de lecture donc ça
c'est agréable
un écran 100% srg
ici c'est un écran ltps 450 need
suffisamment lumineux mais si vous allez
en plein cagnard en plein soleil
on y verra un peu moins bien c'est
normal on va bosser à l'intérieur on
sera mieux ici pourquoi est ce que wade
au fond d'écran 3,2 me et bien parce qu
il cible les professionnels on va pas
dire ciblé le tout achat car on peut
dire cible après des étudiants qui
veulent d'ordi premium qui vont vouloir
mettre 1500 à 1800 euros dans une
nouvelle bécane
on va surtout venir ici chercher du pro
pourquoi du pro et bien parce que
imaginez vous êtes professionnel vous
avez votre tableur vous avez votre
excellent par exemple ou que sais-je
encore bien vous allez pouvoir voir plus
de choses affiché sur l'écran grâce à
cet écran 3,2 me donc ça c'est agréable
ça c'est bien et ça permet d'aller plus
loin en termes de productivité
c'est vraiment l'idée de cette machine
maintenant la contrepartie que vous avez
ici c'est que lorsque vous mettez un
film sur les fixes et compagnie
d'ailleurs je vais vous montrer ça tout
de suite
eh bien la contrepartie c'est que vous
avez des bandes noires qui sont beaucoup
plus grande sur l'eau et sur le bas
forcément les sur du 3 au 8 mais de
notre côté c'est pas très grave parce
que de toute façon vous allez en
profiter de la même manière donc ça
fonctionnera bon ben là ils m'ont mis
des extraits de ces extraits encore
différent dans ça ne mange pas du tout
comme il est tactile
je peux avancer facilement alors c'est
pas le plus adapté effectivement c'est
pas du 16/9 et pour me rallier
productivité et puis un peu de
divertissement ça marchera ça ira bien
alors c'est une machine qui est très
légère elle fait à peine acquis de 33
alors il ya un truc qui est super
intéressant et que je voulais vous
montrer c'est effectivement toute la
partie connectique parce que vous vous
en douterez sur ordinateur on a de la
connectique
alors regardez la connectique vous avez
deux ports usb c'est une prise jack pour
venir brancher un casque bien mais
relativement normale et de l'autre côté
vous avez un usb a donc effectivement
comme ça on se dit c'est vrai il ya
juste l'essentiel il y en a pas des
masses qu'on va venir recharger en usb
c'est donc c'est très simple ça marche
bien mais est ce qui est bien et ce qui
est extrêmement rassurant et ce qui me
plaît bien c'est que vous avez avec à
l'intérieur vous avez ça et ça si
monsieur ben vous avez du vga on a
branché un moniteur en régie à vous avez
du hdmi vous avez une hotte prise usb c
est ici vous avez un autre usb or ça ça
se branche en usb sait d'où l'idée de
venir ajouter un usb site puisque le
condamne au mieux ce bestiau branchant
on en rajoute un autre côté et ce petit
accessoire là eh bien voyez il est
fourni avec
donc ça c'est cool puisqu'on parle
accessoires fournis avec alors ça c'est
normal c'est le chargeur on les sort de
la charge ici charge rapide 65 watts on
a une batterie de 56 water wawa nous
annonçons 11 heures
nomi en bureautique et 10 heures en
usage mixte ça va dépendre de la
luminosité si vous l'a poussé à fond ça
va dépendre de toutes les applications
qui vont tourner derrière donc on va se
dire si on a un peu raisonnable et si
l'on veut pas trop pousser l'histoire un
peu moins de 10 heures on y arrive sans
problème
et lorsque j'aime bien aussi avec ce
petit chargeur qu'on a là c'est que ce
chargeur 60 100 watts il vous sert bien
évidemment à charger votre ordinateur
mais également à charger votre téléphone
notamment votre téléphone de huawei ou
alors à charge et une tablette notamment
une tablette de huawei vous avez deux
ventilateurs à l'intérieur pour venir
dissiper la chaleur des ventilateurs qui
auront plus de palais qui elles
permettront d'apporter meilleure
dissipation de la chaleur tout en étant
moins bruyants vous avez donc deux
degrés de mois par rapport à la
génération précédente et un peu moins de
bruit l'ordinateur qui est récent avec
les dernières technologies et notamment
du wifi 6 alors vous avez bien
évidemment un windows 10 à l'intérieur
ça va de soi aux points qui est
intéressant vous avez un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est situé
juste là pour venir déverrouiller très
facilement leur vous posez votre doigt
sur le bouton pour venir l'allumé sa
déverrouille c'est pratique c'est bien
en plus de ça ils ont dit attendre de
voir oui vous êtes quelque chose qui
marche très bien qui est vraiment bien
c'est ce qu'on appellera whaou est cher
alors ouais cher ça fonctionne entre
smartphones de huawei et un ordinateur
doit au et ça fonctionne également avec
un smartphone de huawei est une enceinte
de huawei je voulais montrer l'autre
jour dans ma vidéo de la loire wilson ça
marche bien c'est super intéressant
et si voyez je n'ai qu'à venir poser mon
smartphone ici il me propose de venir me
connecter au macbook je me connecte
directement sur l'écran au mail mark que
mon père 40 pro souhaite se connecter
toujours autorisé ça ça marche
et ensuite la collection est établi
entre mes deux machines c'est à dire que
je vais avoir du mirroring quand je
viens bouger sur mon smartphone sa
bouche de l'autre côté
donc ça c'est vraiment sympa je peux
venir voir les choses je peux venir
contrôler je peux venir faire beaucoup
de choses donc ça c'est super
intéressant ça me permet ce côté multi
screen si vous voulez et bien de pouvoir
ouvrir deux applications directement
dans mon ordinateur une à gauche une à
droite par exemple est d'avoir le multi
screen en plus alors ce multi screen il
permet aux plus de gérer les appels
téléphoniques directement depuis mon
ordinateur il ya beaucoup d'intérêt à
utiliser aujourd'hui huawei cher je peux
par exemple
renvoyer une photo directement là par
exemple regardez j'ai une photo que j'ai
prise tout à l'heure alors je sais d'une
belle tête de vainqueur dessus et bien
tu as posé mon smartphone directement
dessus up transferts en cours et la
photo elle parle directement dans mon
ordinateur
donc je me retrouve avec la photo ici
dans mon ordinateur elle et enregistrait
directement dans mon ordinateur je peut
transférer des fichiers facilement d'un
côté de l'autre
donc ça me permet une communication
simple intuitif entre mon smartphone et
mon pc pour augmenter la productivité et
comme ici on s'adresse sur un ordinateur
qui est vraiment plus fait pour la
productivité
du coup c'est très bien joué on va donc
se demander à qui est destiné ce macbook
x pro alors comme je voulais dit il puis
destiné aux professionnels il est plus
destiné pour de la bureautique
on pourrait l'imaginer pour des
commerciaux qui partirait en clientèle
quand vous avez une plus grande taille
au niveau de l'écran on aurait le plus
de data qui s'affichera à l'écran plus
de données qui s'afficherait à l'écran
ça c'est vachement même pour tous les
professionnels d'aubade c'est super
intéressant pour venir travailler sous
photoshop vous verrez plus de choses
première c'est pareil vous aurez accès à
plus d'informations par contre c'est pas
un ordinateur qui est dédié pour le
gaming manquera de puissance ça c'est
clair donc on va venir oublier le gaming
ici on peut venir jouer un peu à
quelques jeux mais si on aime les jeux
gourmands tu demandes de la ressource
c'est clairement pas un ordinateur qui
est fait pour vous donc c'est un ordi
que je trouve intéressant i5 16 giga de
ram 512 ya de stockage un petit peu
moins de 1500 euros
il cède 16 giga de ram 1 tera de
stockage tous en ssd un peu moins de
1800 euros je trouve intéressant
intéressant mais ne plaira pas à tout le
monde de par cet écran 3,2 me est ce que
d'ailleurs c'est un format qui pourrait
vous convenir le 3 2 me est ce que vous
verriez vous utilisez aujourd'hui un
ordinateur avec un format 3/2 ouest a
contrario on vous resteriez plutôt sur
un écran 16/9 ça c'est intéressant parce
que c'est vraiment un des gros point
différenciant par rapport au reste du
marché
au delà de la performance au delà du
trackpad avec le retour haptique au delà
tout ça pour moi la grosse différence
c'est la grosse question à se poser
parce que c'est là on passe le plus de
temps on passe plus de temps à regarder
sur l'écran qu'à faire autre chose
est-ce que cet écran 3 demi il vous
plait qu'est ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous pourriez être tenté un
événement marqué moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire et quant à nous on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler de teck a parlé de huawei et
appareils de plein d'autres choses sur
ceux des bisous
et à très vite ciao